that's demi lovato leading a tribute to
the supergroup the Bee Gees for a
special that will air Sunday on CBS
Barry Gibb was there as the only
remaining member of the chart-topping
band we spoke with him it is Miami Beach
home about the enduring music he made
with his brothers and how he's moving on
without them he's the last surviving BG
but at 70 years old Barry Gibb says he's
enjoying being his age the point comes
when young ladies look at you but
they're actually looking over their
shoulder we're webmasters happening
that's the moment what well for someone
like you who was a huge sex symbol what
is that what is that what does that feel
like well I'm an experienced it yeah the
Bee Gees brothers Barry Robin and
Maurice Gibb
recorded or wrote more than 40 top 40
hits across four decades
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
their remarkable career will be
celebrated in a prime-time special
Sunday night on CBS what is having a
special like this movie you it dozens
the thought how much laughter we
actually had how many really nice songs
we came up with
[Music]
and hearing other people sing them 40
years ago this December
the BG scored their biggest success when
Saturday Night Fever was released it
made a movie star of John Travolta
and it's soundtrack would spend six
months at number one we achieved
whatever that dream was whatever
happened afterwards doesn't matter we
got there somehow fever went on to sell
40 million copies and permanently
imprinted the Bee Gees on pop culture
but a series of tragic losses would
shatter the family in 1988 youngest
brother Andy died of drug related causes
in 2003 Morris died suddenly of a
tangled intestine then in 2012 Robyn
lost a long battle with cancer so when I
lost them all um I didn't know whether I
wanted to go on I'm leading a double
life I'm being I'm trying to be me the
individual but I'm also I also feel
passionate that I have to be one of the
Bee Gees no matter what happens
Russia and with this some part of you
that wishes to give that up in some way
no but I have to say that there were
moments when I didn't really want to go
on about it any longer I didn't want to
I didn't want to dwell on loss any
longer
[Music]
in 2014 Barry Gibb finally went out on
his own on his first ever solo tour how
did it feel bittersweet but I loved
being on that stage and I loved those
people and the way they respond to the
songs
[Music]
the concern for me is to find
contentment to be content with
everything in town mmm
or you like content yeah I think ham did
it take you a while to get there yeah it
took me a decade to get there did you
have to change some how do you think yes
I had I I had to give up on issues in
life that I'd had with my brother's I
had to walk away from those things and I
had to get into into a world of half
forgiveness what did you have to forgive
more than anything the sibling rivalry
mm-hmm well we I had to let go of that
it must be difficult to forgive when
you're the only one left if you
understand what I'm saying yeah there's
not a conversation anymore that's been
hard because for me this still has been
a conversation yeah you know I I've
spent many days over that over the last
decade talking to my brothers and
sometimes I talk too much to eat oh it's
it's funny how sometimes you can hear
somebody's voice even louder yes when
they're over that getting used to the
wood no but Mary Gibbs says he's
learning to enjoy just being around sees
life that's the thing that's where you
are now that's where I am now as long as
I'm just after eleven o'clock in the
morning I'm not ceasing anything at all
in the car boy that has a nice touch and
you can watch stayin alive a Grammy
salute to the music of the Bee Gees this
Sunday night at airs at 8:00 7:00
central right here on CBS he has chanted
the five interviewed him four times
since 2009 and every time he's moved a
little further along and dealing with
the loss of his brothers he's come a
long way and that music remains as
influential now as it ever has you could
see the resonance of the questions
before he answered